GOOD MORNING OF THIS RULES
COMMITTEE FOR FRIDAY -- WORK
THIRTEEN TO SURVIVE CALLED
ORDER AND THAT WE WILL CONSTRUED
MAIENSCHEIN TO OUR WHOLE CROWD
-- PLEASE VERIFY IS AN AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDINGS TODAY'S
FOR SENIORS REMAIN AS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
HERE CUNNINGHAM I DON'T CARE
FLORA HERE KAMLAGER-DOVE
YEAH MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
QUIRK SILVA HERE FROM US
HERE REVERSED HERE WORKS
HERE LEVINE -- WE HAVE A
QUORUM -- WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
HELLO SO MOST RELATED CONSENT
AGENDA ISSUE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF RESPECTFULLY HALF
THE PEARL OF AB SIXTY TWO
PEOPLE FROM THE CONSENT AGENDA
DEALS WITH -- FISCAL SYSTEMS
AT LAST YEAR'S SOMERVILLE
WHAT'S REFERRED ACCOUNTABILITY
-- I WOULD ASK THE AB SIXTY
SINGLE OR PER CALENDAR ALL IS
WELL AND I DON'T THINK SO BUT I
-- WE HAVE
A MOTION ON THE REMAINDER
OF THE CONSENT CALENDAR MISS
CARILLO ZERO SECONDS CAN
-- MS QUIRK SILVA
BROADBAND SERVICE CALL THE ROLL
HI COOLEY AYE CUNNINGHAM SIZE
FUNDING I'M I CARILLO CARILLO
AYE FLORA FLORA I KAMLAGER-DOVE
RIGHT KAMLAGER-DOVE IF I
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS BECAUSE I WORK SILVA
QUIRK SILVA I RAMOS FROM
ALSO I READ THIS THREE OF
US I SIGN WORKS I LIVING
LIVING I HAVE MENTIONED
THAT MOTIONS PASSED --
AND SO THE ISSUE IS WE HAVE
A DO OVER FOR ALL MAYBE SIXTY
TWO AS THE PREFERENCE OF
MADE THE COMMITTEE --
IS THERE A MOTION ARE FULL OF AB
SIXTY TWO CONSISTENT
WITH THE RECOMMENDATION FOR A
SIMILAR SENSE OF OUR NATIONAL
THEIR SECOND HOMES CAREER --
MAD SEARCH FOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AWAY FINE COOLEY
AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
NO CARILLO CARILLO AYE
FLORA I KNOW KAMLAGER-DOVE
RIGHT KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN AYE
MATHIS NO MATHIS NO BURKE
SO FAST TIME QUIRK SILVA I
RAMOS DRIVE FROM MOST AYE
REVERSE REVERSE IRAQ'S FIVE
WEEKS I LIVING LEVINE I
-- THE MOTIONS PASS AND
-- COMPUTER WORK MUST